merci d'être avec nous il est 19h47 on
est en direct se touche
pas merci d'être là les chéris merci
d'être avec nous gilberde est là bien
entendu si vous le cherchiez éic cioti
propose d'économiser sur l'aide médicale
aux étrangers pour donner 1500 € par
mois aux agriculteurs êtes-vous d'accord
alors on va expliquer ça c'est une vraie
c'est une vraie proposition euh donc
voilà il propose Eric sootti le patron
des républicains d'aider les
agriculteurs en faisant des économies
sur l'immigration et laame l'aide
médicale et d'État qui av qui permet aux
étrangers en situation irrégulière
d'accéder au soins il veut donner un
salaire minimum aux agriculteurs vous
allez voir combien je suis assez
d'accord avec lui regardez ce qu'il
propose exactement êtes-vous d'accord ou
pas est-ce que déjà je peux voir ceux
qui sont d'accord etc ceux qui sont pas
d'accord oui oui oui oui voilà donc les
les les les les les voilà donc je vois
je savais très bien qui allait dire oui
qui allait dire non et bien entendu euh
je sais qui va plus parler que les
autres aucun agriculteur comp tenu de
leur travail de leur utilité pour le
pays ne doit gagner moins de 1500 €
comment on finance d'abord en accélérant
les aides de la politique agricole
commune ensuite en baissant les impôts
et les charges l'ame qu'on voulait
réformer ça coûte 2 milliards d'euros la
politique sur l'asile et l'immigration
ça coûte 2 milliards d'euros aligné à
1500 € ça aurait un coût de 2 milliards
d'euros pour la collectivité est-ce
qu'on peut pas donner 2 milliards
d'euros à nos agriculteurs et faire des
économies là où c'est
improductif Daniel Mor vous êtes
d'accord évidemment enfin ça tombe sous
le sens moi je suis désolé pour moi la
préférence nationale n'est pas un gros
mot je sais que voilà je vais m'en
prendre plein la tronche de partout mais
c'est pas grave je si les calculs sont
bons je pense que tout le monde est
d'accord pour que les les agriculteurs
aent un salaire minimum descend
maintenant il faut chercher l'argent où
il est moi je trouve qu'il a entièrement
raison voilà et je suis pour la
préférence nationale et et ben JEP de le
dire et pourtant maintenant
c'estté moi j'aimerais bien dire comme
Daniel sauf que ça fonctionne pas comme
ça parce que si tu as un étranger qui
est sur le sol et qui est malade il
attend d'urgence d'État existe si ça
n'existait pas jeends si tuas un
étranger qui est malade tu le payes pas
il se soigne pas lui il va contaminer
quelqu'un d'autre il va être malade il a
des enfants qui mettra à l'école bien
sûr que si bien sûr que si il mettra les
enfants à l'école pas parce que tu vas
pas donner une non mais là tu par Ch
just n'est pas rentré sur le territoire
ayez la franchise de pas faire rentrer
des étrangers sur le territoire une fois
qu'il sont sur le territoire une fois
qu'ils sont sur le territoire vous allez
laisser crever comme des chiens pour
rendre heureux des agriculteurs c'estàd
vous faites crever quelqu'un pour rendre
heureux quelqu'un comme ça que ça
fonctionne l'argent on l'a l'argent on
l'a arrête l'argent on l'a on l' l'ARG
arrê de se mentir en disant parler les
autres quand tu parles sur des trucs a
rien compris parce que l'aide médicale
d'État concerne uniquement les personnes
sans papi les personnes qu'on a laissé
entrer sur le territoire ne bénéficient
pas de l'aide médicale
d'État moi je dire un truc moi aussi je
suis pour la préférence nationale ce qui
est marrant c'est quand Daniel dit ça on
va l'insulter de FAO moi si je dis que
je suis pour la préférence nationale je
m'appelle rad est-ce qu'on va m'insulter
de FAO non on va juste dire que
quelqu'un qui a jamais travaillé de sa
vie tu dones quelqu'un qui a jamais
travaillé de sa vie son se français qui
a jamais bossé de sa vie il est français
tu lu donnes l'aide médicale mais il
faut être sans papier pour
bénéficier'ila s' te plat partons de
truc qui se passe là on parle de truc
c'est l'aide
médicale c'est pour les
PAP pour une aide médicale
d'urgence non je suis pour une aide
médicale d'urgence évidemment qu'il
faut si vraiment les
mecs on par oui alors non mais c'est ça
tu peux expliquer ce que tu veux oui du
coup je disais l'aide médicale d'urgence
existe déjà l'aide médicale d'État
aujourd'hui tu peux tout faire
concrètement avec tu peux te faire des
lunettes tu peux te faire des soins tu
peux tout faire il y a différents degrés
de soins il y a des soins d'urgence
évidemment qu'il faut les maintenir pour
tout le monde la France est un un pays
qui met au cœur de ses valeurs les
droits de l'homme c'est important par
contre l'aide médicale d'État c'est une
énorme funesterie c'est une escroquerie
et euh moi je suis pour toutes les
initiatives qui visent à aider davantage
les agriculteurs et qui visent à
contrôler notre immigration et si on
peut faire des économies au niveau de
notre immigration en la contrôlant et
redistribuer pour les agriculteurs
français qui nous nourrissent qui même
contribuent au rayonnement de la France
à l'international je le fais alors juste
euh Jean-Michel oui moi je suis un peu
sur la même ligne que redouine
évidemment plus que l'aide médicale aux
étrangers fait fait partie de radine
excusez-moi des dispositifs des
dispositifs qui font croire aux gens qui
qui sont dans des dans des situations
désastreuses dans d'autres pays que la
France est un paradis et du coup ils
viennent il se trouvent du coup dans un
endroit qui n'est pas un paradis du tout
il se retrouve dans dans dans dans des
centres et cetera où ils vont peut-être
réexpédier dans leur pays d'origine et
cetera et donc c'est un aspirateur un
miroir aux alouettes et je trouve c'est
ils sont sans papier je préfère en faire
bénéficier des gens qui sont on des
papiers qui crèvent cont tu dis que ceux
qui crèvent dans la rue les paysans
crèvent aussi de fin une fois qu'on aidé
les paysans on est de qui après dès
qu'on a dès qu'on a pris de l'argent
pour les sans papiers on les laisse
crever on a aider les agriculteurs après
faut aider les artisans les boulangers
on tape sur qui
après on va chercher l'ENT hérchie et à
la fin de cette hiérarchie il y a les
étrangers si on a encore un peu d'argent
si on a encore pas on encore peu
d'argent si on était généreux si on
avait une machine à biller évidemment
qu' on aiderait tout le monde tout le
monde a envie d'aider tout le monde tu
peux pas donc est-ce on l'a d'accord bah
si tu l'as propose qu' gasp tu vois pas
l'argent qu'on
gasp non mais ce que dit Jean-Michel
c'est incroyable c'estàd que il dit que
à cause de TI attends il y a le
progressiste à cause de l'aide médicale
progressiste les gens vont venir en
francees
mal y a 420000 personnes qui sont
concernées d'accord vous croyez qu'ils
sont venus ici parce qu'il
SAV tu crois bien sûr que tu crois quoi
absumci il vient son
désespér ches VI en France pour la
tour pour
vient
[Musique]
buar
sit parce que la France l'espoir
pour
par les G s'il vous plaît la la la
France pour plein d'Africains exemple
que je connais bien incarne une sorte de
myth d'Eldorado et ils viennent ici ils
ont tort et ils ont tort de venir ici
parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils vont être
sauvés mais ils viennent pas parce qu'il
y a l'aide médicale d'État ils vient sa
ai s Vinent
ici ce que dire Jean-Michel sans vouloir
le défendre il pas qu'il viennent pour
l'aide médicale d'État juste pour ça ils
disent que comme il vous dit en fait la
même chose il dis
fr ça représente quelque chose et la
France est un pays d'accueil qui qui
fait enc qui fait encore r très généreux
c'est ce que dit Jean-Michel et c'est ce
que tu dis aussi donc vous dites la même
chose et vous vous engueulez donc
qu'est-ce qu' veut le progressist 1
milliard de l'aide médicale détail
surtout pas il faut surtout pas pourquoi
pourquoi parce que ça sauve des gens
parce queon est un pays avec une
tradition d'accueil et on doit continuer
à sauver des gens qui sinon vont
mouriron est-ce qu'on alors c'est un peu
le problème qu'on avait la semaine
dernière aussi oui Daniel on a plus les
moyens tu vois comment on les accueille
mais moi je je ne comprends même pas
évidemment qu'on aimerait accueillir
toute la misère du monde tu vois comment
ils sont justement parce que vu de
là-bas il pensent que la France va être
formidable tu les vois mais moi j'aurais
même honte l'autre jour unidalgo disait
que Paris allait continuer à être une
terre d'accueil mais qu'elle aille à la
Porte de la Chapelle qu'elle voit tous
ces gens par
terreant de penser de bien sûr qu'on a
le mauvais rôle en disant ça moi je vais
m'endre la trche non mais on a le mavais
rôle parce qu'on est les méchant par
qu'on veut pas accueillir des pauvres
gens évidemment qu'on aimerait les
accueillir mais dans ces conditions là
non et ça c'est la l'aide médicale
d'État évidemment ça n'est pas tout mais
c'est une partie de ce qui leur fait
croire que ça va être formidable et
qu'il vont et je suis désolé on ne
laissera pas crever des 100 domiciles
dans la rue parce qu'il y a l'
d'urgenceétat égoïstement pour nous pour
pas que il y ait des maladies qui se
propagent et pour eux aussi on est pas
des sans cœurs complètement
excuse-moi non non je comprends ce que
dit Daniel je je comprends mais moi je
crois pas la sincérité de ericti je
pense que il est juste un
pourquoi c'est normal tu trou tu trouves
des idées sur sur les par rapport
situation monumental parce que a une
politique de droite et tout d'un coup il
dit comment je vais faire pour
exister c'est peut-être pas le genre
mais en tout cas là c'est son genre et
du coup en fait moi ce qui me déplaitt
c'est qu'en fait on déshabille Paul pour
habiller et en
fait agriculteur on va vous donner 1100
€ par mois contentez-vous de ça mais en
fait les agriculteurs ils demandent pas
ils nous l'ont dit t ce qui sont venus
ils veulent pas d'aide ils veulent boss
ils veulent vivre de leur travail ils
veulent avoir une sorte de
respectabilité dans le travail donc 1500
€ en fait c'est une sorte de de et je
pense que même eux ils seraient pas
d'accord je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire c'est en fait là là là là vous là
vous faites un un un débat qui est vous
êtes un peu à côté c'est à côté agric je
vous expliquer pourquoi il a raison
vraiment des AG on sort des agriculteurs
on pense exactement c'est ça l'histoire
parce que ça aurait pas été les
agriculteurs il y a plein de gens qui
sont en difficulté actuellement y a les
commerçants il y a les les boulanger il
y a les infirmiers donc voilà donc en
fait la vraie question la question en
fait que tout le monde se pose et la
question de sous-jacente exactement
là-dedans c'est est-ce que les gars
est-ce qu'on a les moyens aujourd'hui
d'aider comme avant et est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la vraie question
et c'est la question qu'il a soulevé
parce que c'est les agriculteurs qui
sont dans la rue aujourd'hui mais ça
aurait été les boulangersauraiit dit
pareil en fait c'est ça c'est la vraie
exactement il faut changer la question
je mets oui je fais les arguments de
redan en cas
r en cas d'urence non voilà c'est en
fait Raymond tu comprends ce que je dis
c'est que c'est un peu la même question
qu'on a posé sur l'Ukraine en fait un
petit
Peuch donc aujourd'hui il y a de plus en
plus de gens le rit tous les soirs qui
le 10 du mois peuvent plus manger et qui
travaillent de 8h jusqu'à 19h tous les
jours qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas trouver un
moyen on n'est pas on n'est pas on là on
est dans un pour moi là on est dans une
une mesure d'urgence oui
aujourd'hui je je dis il y a de plus en
plus de Français qui sont à la rue
totale et qui peuvent rien faire je le
dis avant ils pouvaient juste survivre
maintenant ils ne peuvent même plus
parce que vivre on oublie he c'està-dire
vivre vers des loisirs en plus ça c'est
faut oublier donc aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on fait et où on va chercher l'argent
c'est tout simplement ça qu'on vous
demande quand il y a eu le covid et je
pense que rayon voulait venir là-dessus
il y a quelques minutes on a trouvé
l'ARG h aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y a
une situation de précarité et surtout
chez les gens qui travaillent
aujourd'hui il faut privilégier les gens
qui travaillent et il faut aider ceux
qui travaillent qui ne s'en sortent pas
travailleurs aujourd'hui la la le
problème qu'on a c'est qu'on aide
beaucoup de gens qui profitent du
système et je vous le dis c'est le gros
problème et c'est des milliards d'euros
et ces milliards d'euros euh c'est
compliqué parce qu'aujourd'hui à un
moment c'est du pas du cas par cas le
problème c'est très compliqué de dire
qui profite du système qui est vraiment
sincère qui donc à un moment il faut
prendre des décisions il a un moment tu
peux pas faire plaisir à tout le monde
c'est le problème de que tu Agil
aujourd'hui tu veux faire plaisir à tout
le monde et c'est pour ça que ta
politique mène dans le mur et que tu es
une politique non pas progressiste mais
une politique passéiste voilà qui est du
passé et qui est exactement toutes les
politiques qui ont été faites jusqu'à
présent et qui font qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans la situation où on en est dans
laquelle en France et qu'aujourd'hui il
y a de plus en plus de gens qui
travaillent et qui s'en sortent pas donc
aujourd'hui l'histoire il Ron tu
comprends tu mettes oui maintenant c'est
ouais est-ce c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
est-ce qu'il faut pas privilégier ceux
qui travaillent et aider ceux qui
travaillent qui s'en sortent pas plutôt
que les assister